Lara sits by the fire on an outcrop in
Peru having just survived a nasty
mauling from two Jaguars you can assume
from context that she's hurt and her
best friend who sits less than six feet
away remarks on it but her face is stony
she hasn't spoken a word since the
attack she's frustrated annoyed having
her momentum halted irritated at the
roadblock she's angry and even her
compassionate nature can't break through
the wall of rage she's built up in her
clashes with Trinity Lara is looking to
get her hands on an artifact before they
do and is doing anything she can to
[ __ ] the organization when she's
asked by a skeptical local why it's so
important to her to keep the artifact
from Trinity she tells her that they are
dangerous it's the same reasoning she's
been using for her entire journey but
now it comes off as a hollow explanation
from a woman who has nothing left but
her thirst for vengeance having watched
the credits roll on Lara's last two
adventures it's hard not to feel both
fond and protective of her her drive is
admirable and her passion for
archaeology is unparalleled but it's
hard to ignore the emptiness under the
surface of her actions in the early
hours of shadow of the Tomb Raider Lara
frequently ignores her basic needs her
wounds and even the well-being of those
around her if they threatened to slow
her down she diverts queries about her
injuries with explanations of her
discoveries without missing a beat
constantly seeking the next step in her
investigation at this point
Lara is running on sheer resolve
a new study published in the Proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences
journal suggests that meaning in one's
life may be healthier than happiness if
this is the case Lara is well on her way
to being the poster child she's clearly
not a happy person but having lost
almost everyone close to her it isn't
hard to imagine why that said she seems
to be losing grip on the meaning in her
life as well
in the first game Lara was a victim of
circumstance
a survivor in rise of the Tomb Raider
she was prepared an adventurer searching
for the final piece of the puzzle from
her father's last mission in shadow of
the Tomb Raider Lara is single-minded
reckless and lethal throughout the
previous game Lara showed a willingness
to put her mission aside if it meant
lives would be saved as she watches a
young boy fall from a building in her
latest mission as a result of a disaster
she may have put in motion it's clear
she's no longer concerned with how her
actions affect others when she escapes
the tsunami her companion Jonah insists
they stay behind to help the survivors
but Lara is steadfast to the point of
obstinate that her mission to stop
Trinity comes first
early on in the lengthy gameplay demo
Lara has a moment of hesitation before
removing a priceless and foreboding
dagger from a tomb what follows is one
of the few breaks in her resolve a
simple what have I done
her dogged pursuit of Trinity also
enables her to ignore what all these
missions and all this murder is doing to
her mental stability towards the end of
rise of the Tomb Raider the Christ from
Trinity soldiers change from the
assumption that they can take her out
easily two phrases like West stuck in
here with her Lara's reputation carries
through into shadow where enemies are
more panicked in her presence
Christ look at her sir her fighting
style has also changed significantly to
reflect the way she has shut out aspects
of her humanity and adopted an icy
resolve while still perfectly capable
with a gun Lara has adopted a dirtier
approach where she will hide in
vegetation walls or slather herself in
mud to strike without warning for new
attacks are brutal animalistic and
underhanded one such ability lets her
string an enemy up by hanging them from
a tree branch with a rope arrow after
killing two Trinity soldiers she wonders
aloud what they're so afraid of the what
she's referring to is a mysterious
violent tribe in the jungle but it's
hard to ignore the irony given it to her
arrows sticking out of their skulls
what are they so afraid of upon
encountering this tribe at the end of
the gameplay demo she shoots on sight
there's enough doubt to suggest they are
as dangerous as she assumes but her lack
of hesitation is a stark contrast to the
young woman who a year prior broke down
after wrestling a gun from an attacker
and shooting him to save herself
after she refuses to aid the injured
civilians Jonah yells at Lara telling
her that not everything is about her
this is directly after she faces the
leader of Trinity who accuses her of
unleashing a tragedy and realizes she
has done exactly as she feared her enemy
would have an understated comment that
stuck with me though is a description of
Lara uttered by a Trinity soldier in one
of the first scenes of the game you have
the photo
female Caucasian early 20s Lara is
admirable and intelligent and the turtle
badass but she's also incredibly young
and while her circumstances aren't
relatable her age is like anyone in
their early 20s it's not so much the
mistake she's making now and the things
that have happened to her but the way
she decides to respond going forward how
she reflects on herself and if she
repositioned her priorities that will
define the person she becomes in the
final chapter of her journey what will I
become